do you think there's been a steady sort
of Rise of this sort of behavior or the
behavior of this scale is it still quite
isolated
uh Fortune I think the latter
um I I can't ever remember seeing
anything like this before uh the PGA put
out a statement this morning sent a
report and I can't think of a better
word it's just absolutely appalling I
can't imagine you know when I refereed
at that level ever coming back through
an airport and
I would just be horrified if something
like that happened and I feel so much
for Anthony's Family you know he's had
such a brilliant season
this is a culmination of what is a
fantastic season as I tried to explain
to people this morning if you look at
this CV this year he went to the World
Cup he was kept on towards the end of
the competition and through no fault of
his own England's progress impacted on
his chances being appointed for the
final uh the biggest competition in
Europe the Champions League he's been in
a similar position with Manchester
City's progress has impacted again on
his chance of a final and he's got the
second best competition in Europe the
Europa final he's gone out there you
know to represent his country to
represent his family to referee the
referee and body
and coming back that will be tarnished
forever you know he he will never forget
that you know and it's just terrible was
the word I used a sport and I can't
think of a better word well and and
obviously this the sort of physical uh
abuse here and uh and being swarmed and
surrounded with with family members is
obviously the biggest thing you're
referring to is that totally the
responsibility of those fans that are
that are doing that or can it be linked
to the very clear ongoing protests that
the referee uh faced from the manager
Jose Mourinho uh of those fans that
perhaps they look up to him or is it is
it is it unfair on Mourinho to try and
draw that link
well I think it's it's difficult to
speculate what you've got to do you've
got to talk about things in isolation
certainly the um it was just so so
unlucky that Anthony had to go through
the airport with his family when there
was so many Roma fans there you know
that that was just coincidental because
of their flights but that said you know
they should respect you know he he's
done his job he's done his job to his
best visibility I actually think he's
done a really good game I think he's one
of the most testing matches I've ever
seen he stood up to it strong he had
numerous challenges throughout the whole
match and bearing in mind Not only was
it a two-hour match with penalties there
was 30 minutes added on as well so it's
his mental strength everything was
fantastic and
all power to him for getting through it
like that and he certainly does not
deserve this his family does not deserve
this I just hope this never ever happens
again to any referee anywhere in the
world
but but just to my point about the
Mourinho uh protests and criticism we've
had an incident earlier in the season
from Jurgen klopp being being avert in
his criticism of a referee which he's
since apologized for do you think that
people in positions of responsibility
like that need to massively dial back
criticisms of referees but because it
might one way or another enable further
protests
whether there is a procedure isn't
there's a procedure for managers not
happy with the referee's performance if
I referee your team and you're
dissatisfied with my performance as a
procedure you go through and that's set
out quite clearly
um there's an opportunity for a manager
to go and see a referee 30 minutes after
a game in the Premier League and speak
to him about decisions but it doesn't
give you the opportunity to go and
berate an official it doesn't give you
the opportunity to
um publicly slam him like we've said
um and that's that's when the
authorities step in